[Musique]
fabriquer de l'énergie à partir de ces
crevettes c'est possible des mêmes
l'objectif de cette unité de
méthanisation à ribeauvillé
créé par des exploitants agricoles du
secteur elle traite chaque année jusqu'à
35 mille tonnes de déchets organiques
issus de l'agriculture de la
restauration ou encore de la grande
distribution
ces revenus seront traitées grâce à un
digesteur une cuve qui à l'image de
votre estomac est capable de produire du
gaz en dégradant les déchets après la
production de biogaz
on a deux moteurs qui ont utilisé ce
biogaz à la place de l'essence et qui
vont produire de l'électricité et de la
chaleur sur notre sol autres
installations
on produit on peut produire aujourd'hui
quinze mille mégawatts électriques qu'on
injecte dans le réseau ce qui permet de
couvrir les besoins de pratiquement 15
mille habitants en électricité
tous les jours 24 heures sur 24
la chaleur produite par l'installation
sert à alimenter un casino et une
fromagerie à proximité le surplus
réutilisés sur place ici rien ne se perd
le résidu de la production du gaz le
digestat sert d'engrais pour les
cultures
ce principe de méthanisation est très
intéressant et très vertueux puisque ici
met en place un système totalement
circulaire assez innovant puisque on va
on apporte des solutions pour traiter
les déchets organiques qui sont produits
sur un territoire grâce à ses déchets
organiques
on va produire de l'énergie renouvelable
et locale et grâce à 7
ce procédé de méthanisation on va
obtenir nous agriculteurs des matières
fertilisantes 100% naturel qu'on avait
ça c'est vraiment intéressant
le site de ribeauvillé est l'une des
plus grosses installations françaises en
termes de production électrique une des
pépites alsacienne des énergies
renouvelables c'est pour cette raison
qu'une visite de la structure s'est
retrouvé au programme de sa turbine dans
le haut rhin une semaine de réflexion
sur les énergies en transition initiée
par le conseil départemental qui s'est
tenu du 15 au 19 octobre
cette turbine sait faire partager
beaucoup de projets qui existent déjà
qui sont encore en cours d'exploitation
comme quelques micro turbines sur le
canal du gharb désaffecté des panneaux
fauteuils des projets promouvoir des
projets de production de l'énergie
renouvelable visites d'entreprises
conférences animations un objectif
ouvrir le débat et la réflexion au plus
grand nombre que l'on soit spécialistes
ou non la transition énergétique
concerne tout le monde
justement l'idée c'est de sortir des
cercles d'experts qui travaille sur la
princesse naïm et qui travaille sur la
transition énergétique pour donner la
parole à nos concitoyens et qu'ils
puissent eux aussi et c'est important
enrichir le projet de l'après fessenheim
et le projet de la transition
énergétique de notre territoire
objectif annoncé par le conseil
départemental faire du haut rhin le
premier département français en terme de
production d'énergie renouvelable
une façon d'envisager positivement la
préfet sunlights même si la collectivité
territoriale aurait préféré voir la
centrale restait en service quelques
années de plus nous y prenons pas seul
nous nous y prenons avec l'ensemble des
partenaires locaux et aussi avec l'état
avec un certain nombre de projets qui
sont portées par part et df qui sont
portées par l'état où d'autres acteurs
demain il s'agit de remplacer clairement
la centrale de fessenheim par une
vitrine c'est un petit peu mon rêve
une vitrine des énergies renouvelables
sur le site de fessenheim
nous estimons que c'est un défi pour
l'avenir
nous l'avons pris en tant que tel et un
beau défi avec la possibilité avec
l'ensemble des acteurs locaux de
dessiner pour demain la transition
énergétique question énergie verte le
département dispose déjà de beaux atouts
leur a laissé barrages hydroélectriques
la plus grande centrale photovoltaïque
d'alsace à ungersheim au conseil
départemental c'est vers cette énergie
que l'on souhaite se tourner dans un
premier temps le service environnement à
d'ores et déjà été créés un recensement
des espaces qui pourrait être dévolu à
la production des puits solaire
bah il fallait repérer toutes les
surfaces artificialisées qui permettant
de nous installer des panneaux
photovoltaïques dont nous allons avoir
repéré dans à travers le département
plus de 300 hectares donc maintenant
petit à petit il faut monter les
dossiers et puis voir si la faisabilité
de ces projets
autre piste de réflexion pour la
production d'énergie l'autoproduction
chez moba solar on est spécialisée dans
le photovoltaïque le créneau de ce
bureau d'études
le tout consommation des particuliers
avec quelques panneaux et batterie un
particulier peut ainsi couvrir
simplement et sans se ruiner environ un
tiers de sa consommation annuelle
d'électricité chacun peut devenir son
propre producteur d'énergie à son niveau
aussi bien qu'ils soient locataires ou
propriétaires bien sûr un propriétaire à
plus de facilité et qui peut installer
ces panneaux sur une toiture au jardin
un locataire c'est un peu plus délicat
mais avec des solutions nomades commun
développer il là il a aussi la
possibilité des produits en partie de
son énergie qui va consommer et être en
autonomie contrairement à une idée reçue
le solaire n'est pas réservé aux pays
très ensoleillé il suffit qu'il fasse
jour pour qu'une cellules
photovoltaïques produisent du courant
bien sûr la production d'énergie dépend
de l'ensoleillement mais en alsace on
est plutôt bien loti en alsace
contrairement à ce qu'on pense son
introduction minimum si les pannes sont
incliné à 30 degrés d'environ 1000
kilowatts heure pour un kilowatt crête
installé c'est à dire si on a ça les
trois panneaux de 330 watts on va
arriver à produire à peu près 1000
kilowatts heure sur l'année
autre avantage des énergies
renouvelables on peut les mettre en
place avec des savoir-faire et des
technologies locales
dans le cas du photovoltaïque mauvais
solar propose des panneaux fabriqués en
alsace monté par des installateurs
locaux